my name is Yan xuetong at just the Korea
and the title of my talk is mathematics
of a series using the symbolic computing
package I'm going to give a brief
introduction of the package and I show
you some examples of using the package
of functions from manipulation and
evaluation of mathematical expressions
my presentation is in the mathematics of
series with Somali computing packaging
my name is Jim to town and I'm from gist
Korea the overview of my talk I'm going
to give you a brief introduction of the
Somali computing package II hope you and
the previous story and then I'll show
you some of the functions that are used
for mathematics of the series corner and
the pegida functions and I show you some
examples for using the functions in the
package all these topics I chose these
topics will show you that the
mathematical as is it is not enough to
evaluate these quantities like definite
integration here and the residue and the
Fourier series approximate the solution
of nonlinear hoodie and asymptotic
behavior of the airy functions ie well
about small e computing package
well the key words of the package is the
mathematical calculation the
computer-aided mathematics and the small
ik and algebraic computation for
handling mathematical expressions the
overview
okay well this is a dump I package that
facility is Kampala computation with the
mathematical expressions but everything
but especially for the mathematical
expressions and it has over 800
functions and it has its own programming
kind of a language and it is used to
display and the interpretation of
various mathematical expressions like
derivatives integrals sums the best
operator is brackets etc using the
traditional notation so all these
quantities are displayed using the
traditional notation but it is still in
this standard form is not a traditional
form and the package has its own code
for interpretation and the display of
these quantities it was written by me
the motivation it is to design and
implement a small e computing system
based on that America that can
manipulate the various mathematical
expressions using traditional notation
and the deferred on demand evaluation
the difference with that course when you
load the package e is there some of the
quantities like the Psalms integrals
products etc are not evaluated and these
quantities are evaluated by using the
calling the function they starts with
the evaluate something and there are
some twenty or thirty functions to
evaluate for evaluation of the
expressions and it is deployed on demand
evaluation so objective is to replace
handwritten in calculation with the
symbolic computing and software based on
automation and the features it allows
traditional notation
algebraic manipulation and etc and it
provides a powerful platform for
streamlined manipulation of the
mathematical expressions here I show you
some of the examples here before I go
ahead
I load the packages okay all of the
functions in the package they start with
SC meaning smollett computing and for
example SEC very big spend and then this
is expanding this already
visit output and SEC transform
derivative so we have a second
derivative of F and this is the option
for specification of transformational
variables so the only variables X and XI
and noob Arabs are Christian DITA and
then this is the transformed Liberty and
since these integrals are not evaluated
these two integrals are Maajid
automatically and see back expand this
is a pretty complicated quantity call of
this a and F will be these are all bad
functions so a and B vector functions f
is a scalar function and if you expand
it and you have this result and
sequential execution of functions as I
see em a function undoes this and we can
through navigation using the SECNAV
palette which is this by the way this is
the palette for controlling the
execution of the function synthesis so
here we have an integral and the
transient this is a function for
transformation of integral and the
trades bar this is the old and a new
variable and X is 850 and this is
composition of functions but is
exploited in the reverse order or
simplify poet stand and the metagame is
executed in the reverse order and if you
do that then we have this result and
then well this as you can see this
integral is not evaluated then I call as
evil inch then it is and the result is
even extended compositional functions
[Music]
okay we have second order differential
equation here and this is the series
form of solution and then put it in here
and expanded these derivatives and here
well again this is a function
composition it's executed in the reverse
order so you built a div with the pry
means X derivative and expand factor
some and divide the result with X to R
and then put everything inside the sum
and then shifted a variable in the sum
so if I executed where they are about
six six functions and if I do that then
this is the result so this is the
expansion of the differential equation
in series and then we can obtain initial
trajan and the recordin relation from
this result okay so this is the final
form and as you can see this must be
zero and therefore we have a double root
for our zero and this must be zero and
this is the recursion relation and if
you solve it and basically equation is
dissolved in series form so advantages
are very clear we can prove we have a
close emulation of handwritten
calculation etc and we have a good
readability ok the brief history this
was well development studied about 15
years ago and about five years of a beta
testing and next month it is going to be
released as a commercial product this is
a plan
we have a documentation and I'm can I
show you a whole documentation but this
is the title page of the technology and
then here this reference and index these
are the or list of functions in the
package and index all functions let me
go back
oops
[Music]
under light oh I see
alright ok the functions for series well
there are several color and the package
of functions associated with the series
and the series a function expand for
example this up to the second degree of
x and y but the problem is we have up to
portolo
if x and y are small quantities and they
disappear TV series and there's one
function in the packages Taylor series
and X Y P this function expands up to
the specified order for all variables so
it is it doesn't have like X square Y
square things like so we have only the
second order for both x and y and the
power series gives an infinite series so
this is expanded first true to this poem
and then this is expanded using binomial
series in this form so this is complete
infinite series for this expression and
the power series supports for all of
these functions the kinds of functions
and the DS function can be expanded
using the power series as an infinite
series this shows an example of analysis
this is the result well this is a
analytical solution for small amplitude
oscillation and this is a numerical
solution with no approximations and you
can see where for small oscillation then
you have to expand it to the the first
folder in Taylor series and here we have
a function and there are six variables
if you use series then you will have up
to six over actually but the Taylor
series here the peak to the function
expands only to the first order for all
these variables so you don't have to
collect the terms that only the first
and it is done automatically by by
dysfunction okay I assure you both
examples evaluation of the application
well this one looks very easy but
actually this is the function I found
this problem in pora and directly
integration does not work this is very
simple but and integrated doesn't work
so expand the DS in through a power
series okay then this exponential can be
expanded and you can see how this is
going to proceed so by the way this is
the palette to control the execution and
then this can be you can evaluate it but
I transform again using using this rule
he is equal to minus 12x then is
transformed to this form and again well
this is going to be the integral for
factorial function this is n factorial
so so this is canceled and then this is
the final form it is in series form but
it can be evaluated numerically so it is
this is the result and now this series
converges pretty rectally as you can see
with the ten perms it is about order of
ten to minus 10 so it's very accurate
and the past numerical integration using
SSE well in any gives the same result
next one
evaluation of the residue well this one
is it has isolated singularity and if
you evaluated using
using the the system function it doesn't
evaluate but using this definition again
definition again and then doing the
transformation and expanding into power
series and they combine the double sums
and then using this formula from the
complex variable then we have this
result so it is transformed to this
integral and this integral is expanded
in series completely this is infinite
series and the berry and the dis series
this is a double sum and it is it does
not evaluate if you call some function
as is it has not abated but if you
convert it using this rule using n plus
P is changed to N and then n ranges from
0 to infinity or T ranges from 0 to n so
this is a finite finite sum
- fine I - some like this then if you
evaluate for P only P only then we get
this result so this is a single song in
N and the business arm can be evaluated
and the result is written in terms of
hyper geometry Pikachu function and this
is the closed form expression and we can
evaluate a numerical value the disease
the result we can compare it using
numerical evaluation of this integral
and it gives the same result
okay evaluation of the Fourier series
well this is the question what is the
closed form or this pure series this is
a periodic function with a period of two
the period of true and if you plot it
using different number of terms for
example with the just one term it is a
cosine five times ten pounds and twenty
terms and you can see it is a periodic
with a period of two and we can obtain
where the result will be a polynomial
polynomial between plus minus one and
this one can be actually evaluated I
tried it so if I evaluate the sum it is
the first pivot result is given in terms
of Holy Roller function but it doesn't
give a much insight about the behavior
of the function so I call a function
expand if I do that then this is the
result then I do post processing for
these three functions in series and the
result is surprisingly it's very simple
it's given so this is the code for
expression valid between plus minus 1
and it is periodic so we know the
function for hold T but alternatively we
can use the method of Fourier series to
derive
the same expression so I start with this
and if I evaluate the value is 4 0 and 1
then it is given by these and the diesel
Psalms are is pretty unique it's
Elementary and these are the result then
the differential equation this is
infinite cosine and if you try to
evaluate it it'll not because this is
Newton is sound and it is not convergent
but using the theory of Fourier series
you can show that it is written in terms
of a Dirac Delta function this is the
result so this is some even though this
is a divergent it is a singular function
and it has a singularity at the T equals
to K minus 1 but otherwise it's all 0 so
we have result indicates that this is
equal to Phi square over 2 but the first
derivative is a discontinuous at the 2t
minus 1 so the solution must be the
solution of this differential equation
using these boundary conditions and this
is the result so we have obtained the
same same result and if we plot f key
you can see it's exactly same plot of
time well approximate the solution of
the nonlinear oh de well the solution of
nonlinear de doesn't have it doesn't
have standard established the procedure
for solving the equations so we have to
do many trials and errors and the
leading behavior of the solution it can
be shown that is given by this and I
skipped the derivation and a is the
location of the movable
second order for similarity and then if
you assume the Laurent series for a so
sufficiently close to X
equals a so assume this series form and
put it in the differential equation here
and this is a fairly complicated code
for manipulation of this differential
equation I'm not going to go through all
this but eventually I end up with the
solution for the a frictions up to N
equals 3 and the recursion relation is
given by this and then the recursion
relation for end rather than or equal to
5 it is given by this so if you know the
value on the right side the sum it is
when the terms are from a minus 1 up to
n minus 1 which are supposed to be all
known using the recursion relation and
then using all these values you can
calculate the end coefficient so if you
generate to the question for n up to 10
then you can see where is a 0 to a 1
then this is the first a non-vanishing
question it be a 4 but here a POI is
arbitrary so we have a one constant of
equation and then a is also constant it
is a move over similarity and therefore
a and se are the two three parameters
and the DS are determined by the
boundary conditions so if we plot a
series of solution for different values
of a and the C so a is the this is the
similarity if I move it and well
actually this is a solution of series
series of solution and therefore it is a
it can be not only within the radius of
convergence and also I did with a low so
this is the series is restricted to the
region of convergence and see this is
the second parameter and
the sea is changing then by using
manipulating a and the sea we can
satisfy the boundary conditions a true
boundary conditions and the problem of
the numerical solution well this
equation can be solved numerically using
NDS are we value and well because there
is a singularity we have all these error
messages and let me turn them off okay
so here this is a solution with the y 0
equal to 0 Y Prime you know he's also 0
but if I change the boundary condition
then we have a different solutions and
one of these solutions can be it is it
coincides with one of those solutions
obtained using the series but you can
see under the negative axis is actually
true but this is outside the range of
convergence and therefore we do not see
and analysis of the function in this
area must be done using other methods or
the asymptotic series okay finally when
we go briefly over asymptotic behavior
of Airy functions
this is Airy region and this is a
integral representation of AI and then
using the complex analysis the
stationary points are here and here but
news the stationary point in the upper
half plane we cannot use it you cannot
use it because this one we have to go
upwards but there is a singularity here
so we here the result is not it's not
convert it is not convergent is it
diverges and therefore we cannot use it
but if you use the disk or I'm not for
but that this point is stationary point
and then
okay and then using the Taylor expansion
and then take them out and finally the
integral can be transformed to this form
and it really is a Gaussian and easily
relative and that this is the result for
for negative G the stationary points are
here and here so we had to pick up the
contributions from both the stationary
points and if I do that this is more
complicated and the code for doing the
analysis it's given here and if I
execute it so area is when Jesus name
ative it is given by by this term and
assume series asymptotic series the
function it returns the same result when
the argument G of less than Phi so for G
which is not real negative this is a
true for all complex G other than the
real negative axis it is hewn by this
and on the negative real axis it is
given by this and the early I is more
restricted so for this condition is
given here and this for negative real
axis is given by this the full
asymptotic expansions is given here this
is infinite sum and this is the hammer
symbol and so this is a fool asymptotic
expansion as you see awesome series
supports these functions quite a lot and
these functions here the packages in
those here the formula for the synthetic
expansion for these functions so if I
plot the area function with one poem you
can see it's a pretty accurate but if
you plot the error is quite a
significant it's all about 4000 one with
the two thumbs
air is very much reduced three terms and
the five terms so with more terms it is
very accurate had four logics but error
increases or small X and similarly for
early bi with one form two thumbs three
thumbs and the five terms
okay that's all and thank you for your
attention